you said what my thought bubble was
which was you listened you listened
[Music]
first up we've got the sweetest story
about actor and dad john stamos the blog
scary mommy reports that he just posted
this video of his son billy
watching his new favorite show
this is funny
oh
now john says that billy was never
interested in full house in fact he was
on the show and he talked about that
um
and
all of a sudden his son
is in the full house
and i don't know if it has john or
people wondering if it has anything to
do with maybe bob saget above alluring
like billy into his orbit
but
recently billy has been obsessed oh
that's very very sweet and like welcome
to the club billy i grew up on um on
full house did you watch it when you
were growing up i did watch it yeah of
course my god have mercy
first step in the headlines this one's
fun online dating is just never easy for
anyone as you all well know i certainly
know apparently it isn't for zac efron
either
buzzfeed reports that zach got on tinder
a few years back and said he never even
got a swipe right oh well
i know i'm like come on and it's not
just him
shaq says that he struck out too you got
a zack and a shack and they both struck
out and some celebs have had luck online
though simone biles met her current
boyfriend jonathan owens they're so cool
dating app reya oh yeah yeah that's a
big one um i mean i think my only guess
is that what people thought it wasn't
really him yeah that's it i do buy that
people didn't believe it was really zac
efron because can you imagine not
swiping i mean my finger would be bloody
from like swiping
so first up scorned taylor swift lover
jake gyllenhaal is speaking out
l reports jake has not listened to
taylor's red album or the song about him
but he says it has nothing to do with
him it's between taylor and her fans and
she uses her personal life in her music
i feel like jake gets it
right but that being said jake did turn
off the comments on his instagram when
the album came out and about that he
said and i quote here i think it's
important when supporters get unruly
that we feel a responsibility to have
them be civil and not allow for cyber
bullying in one's name
in
one's
name i mean i think we all know the name
that he means though
right yeah i think that part's great i
will say and i i like jake gyllenhaal i
just don't believe that he hasn't
listened to the album okay i'm sorry i'm
sorry but it puffed the magic dragon if
it was about me i would listen to it you
know like and i would study every single
lyric do you think come on
you said what my thought bubble was
which was you listened you listened
first up
we all try to keep track of all the
important birthdays in our lives but
sometimes we mess up and one mom in
minnesota bravely admits that she had
the wrong birthday for her
three-year-old son i love the story
people reports emily vondrachek says
she's only figured it out when her
insurance company had a different date
in their records they flagged it when
she went back to check her own birth
announcement on facebook she stood
corrected watch this
his birthday is indeed the 25th
for two years
i've been celebrating his birthday on
the 26th
and now i have to call my pediatrician
back and say haha you know what
i had my kids birthday wrong you want to
know the worst part the worst part
it's my middle child
hilarious
and why you know it's not great okay but
i'm not going to mom shame you i'm not
going to do it i will i thought about
angelina jolie didn't she get like
tattoos of the longitude latitude or the
birth dates of all her kids or something
that's a good idea or
if you don't want to do a tattoo you
could just be like hey siri you know
remember this day forever that'll work
too
[Music]
you